et pour en débattre nous sommes avec un
nacira guénif professeur de sociologie
et d'anthropologie à l'université paris
8 membres du collectif vidal démission
bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés cécile relax député la
république en marche troisième
circonscription du val d'oise bonsoir
madame relax merci d'être avec nous
également frédéric vidal qui a donc un
dénoncer on l'a vu dans les colonnes du
jdd un procès d'intention à son égard
est ce que la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche a eu raison
de dénoncer ce courant de l'islamo
gauchisme rampant au sein des
universités et de réclamer en tout cas à
minima une enquête il ya clairement un
danger c'est si leur île
selon vous il y a pour moi pas de danger
mais il faut faire attention aux termes
employés
là où je ne suis pas d'accord vous jeudi
que en effet notre ministre a eu un
écart de langage sans voyons le mot
islam gauchisme l'âge
en effet je ne cautionne pas ce terme
employé je ne suis pas là c'est
d'ailleurs par contre ce que la ministre
a voulu dénoncer c'est une problématique
qui est latente depuis quelques années
où l'ia dans certaines universités n'ont
pas de la part des enseignants
chercheurs mais de la part des étudiants
de certains groupuscules une un amalgame
qui est fait un mélange de genres qui
est fait entre eux la logique de
recherche
la logique scientifique et le
militantisme et l'utilisation politique
de certains concepts
en fait je pense que là où la ministre
elle a raison de dire attention il y à
des concepts qui sont détournés
oui il faut qu'on y fasse attention donc
là elle parle petit clairement de
théories en sciences humaines et
sociales
on va parler d'un terreau sectional it
et on va parler des colonialismes tout
ça mais là où en effet moins donc plus
je ne peux pas cautionner l'utilisation
du terme islam au gauchisme pas que cela
renforce ce mélange des genres qui à mon
sens n'est pas bon alors en tout cas le
monde universitaire on l'a dit est vent
debout et demandent sa démission à la
mini
str propose de revoir un extrait de
cette tribune publiée ce week-end dans
le journal bien le monde
si le propos manque de cohérence
l'intention est dévastatrice
il s'agit de diffamer une profession et
au delà toute une communauté
la taxe ne se limite d'ailleurs pas à
disqualifier puisqu'elle fait planer la
menace d'une répression intellectuelle
nous ne pouvons que déplorer l'indigence
de frédéric vidal la violence du projet
redouble de la lâcheté d'une ministre
restée silencieuse sur la détresse des
étudiants et étudiantes pendant la
pandémie alors nacira guénif vous vous
faites partie de ces signataires et vous
demander clairement départ de frédéric
vidal qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
choqué finalement dans cette affaire je
pense que ce qui est le plus choquant
c'est l'opportunisme le cynisme je ne
sais pas comment il faut lire dont fait
preuve la ministre alors que le monde
universitaire dans une situation
d'isolement de désorganisation de
détresse profonde dire cela en pleine
pandémie
face à des étudiants qui ne sont pas
tenues d'ailleurs un quelconque devoir
de réserve du point de vue de leurs
opinions politiques
ils ne sont pas tenus à la scientificité
sont là pour apprendre
donc je ne suis pas absolument sûr de
comprendre la position de l'adema dames
la députée donc du point de vue deux des
signataires qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus
six ans ils sont treize mille nous
sommes treize mille signataires du monde
universitaire a demandé la démission le
départ de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche parce que
alors vous comprendrez contre 6600
vendredi et 13000 aujourd'hui il y a
comme une unanimité que la ministre
doit assumer un sait les conséquences de
ces propos et aussi de ses actes je ne
ne suis pas la seule à me souvenir que
depuis quatre ans toute une série de
lois de projets on visait à mettre en
coupes sombres l'enseignement supérieur
public français et c'est donc face à
cela que aujourd'hui nous considérons
que ces propos sont parfaitement déplacé
que c'est une manoeuvre de diversion
qu'elle a opéré pour détourner le regard
du fait qu' elle n'a pas cessé en fait
d'agir contre les intérêts du monde
universitaire et qu'elle s'est
désintéressé
depuis de longs mois du sorte
d'étudiantes et d'étudiants qui
aujourd'hui sont complètement livrés et
abandonné à une situation qui devient
proprement insupportable
et ce ne sont pas que les étudiants se
sont aussi les enseignants chercheurs et
tous les précaires de l'enseignement
supérieur qui aujourd'hui écoute avec
effarement des propos de la ministre
alors la maison ainsi sur le fait de
vouloir faire une enquête sociologique
étant moi même formé en sociologie
anthropologie je crois pouvoir en parler
en toute en toute quiétude
je ne devrais pas être ici pour
contester les propos de la ministre je
devrais être en train de faire le
travail pour lequel j'ai été formé et
pour lequel je suis fonctionnaire
or je dois aujourd'hui contesté les
propos du ministre et mettre en évidence
le fait que ce projet de recherche d'
enquête est absolument complètement
fumeux il n'y a aucune priorité aucune
urgence à examiner
quoi que ce soit qui serait approchant
d'un phénomène d'islam au gauchisme au
sein de l'université française alors
c'est sillery là que les raisons
invoquées par frédéric vidal au départ
c'était protéger un jeu signe des
universitaires se disant empêché par
d'autres de mener leurs recherches
séparer ce qui relève de la recherche
académique de ce qui relève du
militantisme et de l'opinion est ce
qu'il y a clairement un problème de
métal parce que quand on écoute un
madame gheniff on voit effectivement que
la contestation au sein du monde
universitaire
randy de jours environ 2 600 signataires
dans la colonne du band on passe à 13
milles
elle aurait dû s'y prendre autrement la
ministre s'est en fait et on est à un
carrefour de différentes choses que ce
que madame guenifi dénonce il ya un
cumul on entend bien qu'à la
problématique en effet des étudiants la
situation des universités qui est
extrêmement difficile depuis la crise qu
vide donc ça en effet sa cristallise
beaucoup beaucoup de désespoir de
désespérance la part de nos étudiants et
c'est tout à fait normal que les
enseignants les enseignants chercheurs
et ben soit inquiet pour pour leurs
étudiants donc ça et ça c'est une
première chose ensuite il y a pour
certains jeux universitaires une
opposition liées à la loi de
programmation sur la recherche on les
estime que cette loi ne va pas assez
loin or on a mis 25 milliards d'euros
sur les prochaines années pour supérieur
et la recherche
donc bon gales et enfin on arrive à
cette problématique là comme je vous ai
dit que le terme islam au gauchisme moi
je ne je ne cautionne pas les propos de
la ministre par rapport à cela mais par
contre là où madame gheniff il faut
quand même le reconnaître c'est que dans
certaines universités aujourd'hui on a
une problématique qui est que certains
jeux je le redis c'est bien des
groupuscules ce ne sont pas les
enseignants ce sont des groupuscules
étudiants ou alors au même en extérieur
d'université qui empêche le dialogue qui
empêche le débat sur certains concepts
et hébron moi ce que la ministre c'est
cela qu'elle a voulu dénoncer de dire
attention dans certains dans certaines
universités
il n'y a plus la possibilité de débattre
il n'y a plus la possibilité de
confronter des idées des des concepts
différents or l'université c'est quand
même bien le lieu celle ci le droit
d'être moi c'est très important
et pardonnez moi parce qu'on on arrive
dans le coeur du sujet parce que quand
on les voit ici ou là l'islamo gauchisme
et bien franchement c'est pas toujours
bien ce que c'est donc justement c'est
quoi ces concepts dont on ne peut pas
parler franchement on bien qu'on
comprenne de quoi il s'agit en fait de
quoi on parle
alors si vous voulez que je vous donne
une définition d'islam au gauchisme
personnellement je ne
parce que c'est en tout cas moi j'ai été
traitée aussi par les soirées devant les
concepts par contre où il est qui qui
entraîne des problématiques dans les
universités c'est quand on va utiliser
des théories aujourd'hui qui sont en
effet étudié en sciences humaines qui
sont le des colonialismes qui sont
l'intersexualité ou et où on voit qu'il
ya des groupes d'étudiants qui discutent
et qui vont interdire des réunions
mixtes qui vont faire justement des
réveillons des mixains qui vont empêcher
des conférences de se tenir
qui vont cesser cela en fait qui est
dénoncé c'est c'est voyez la différence
à dire que ce n'est pas le contenu
les enseignants et des enseignements qui
est dénoncé c'est l'exploitation par
certains groupes politiques et à des
fins militantes d'empêcher l'expression
de différentes conceptions
voilà donc ce sont ces enfin je pense à
la base mais je pense que madame gheniff
là-dessus sera d'accord avec moi que
c'est sur ces théories 2
intersectionnelle été particulièrement
des colonialismes se pose la difficulté
et madame gheniff je pense que vous êtes
d'accord que ce n'est pas normal que
dans certaines universités ne puisse pas
se tenir des conférences qui les ondes
et des intervenants des chercheurs
qu'ils ne puissent pas exposer leur
approche
deux de ces données ou qu'on organise
des réunions qu'ils soient interdites à
certaines personnes
on va laisser nacira guénif répondrez
vous répondrais ce que vous constatez où
ce genre de phénomène clairement dans
notre université
non je n'ai pas croisé groupuscules et
je n'ai pas connaissance de la part de
tous les enseignants chercheurs et tous
les collègues avec lesquels j'interagis
depuis des années maintenant de quoi que
ce soit qui relève d'une action de
groupuscules qui viendrait empêcher le
débat ou qui souhaiteraient se
faire sécession pourquoi pas séparatisme
tant qu on n est ce pas un puisqu'il ya
quelques jours noirs là dessus a été
votée donc allons jusqu'au bout de de la
tendance et de la pente glissante sur
laquelle on veut nous installer non je
pense que les étudiants et les étudiants
sont parfaitement en droit de
s'approprier les théories qui sont
enseignées à l'université pour être très
clair
j'enseigne les théories des colonials
j'enseigne les théories du genre
j'enseigne les théories de
l'intersection qualités et j'ai face à
moi des groupes d'étudiants qui sont
parfaitement capables d'assimiler ce que
je leur enseigne d'en comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants est
d'ailleurs souvent ils sont et elles
sont tout à fait capables de voir en
quoi est-ce que ça résonne par rapport à
la vie qu'il mène en france notamment
par rapport au phénomène de racisme
structurel ou par rapport au phénomène
de discrimination de sexisme et des et
de racisme croisés donc ces théories
sont très utiles elles n'ont pas à être
évalués par une enquête extérieure qui
viendrait nous expliquer qu'elles ont
une légitimité quelconque cela se passe
dans lance dans l'enceinte de
l'université au sein des espèces de
controverse et de débats et il n'y a
aucune nécessité de réguler ces espaces
pour le moment qu'il y ait eu des
annulations de conférences ça reste
parfaitement minoritaires par l'ensemble
de toutes les activités qui se déroulent
dans les universités et qui ont
malheureusement été interrompue en
présence depuis le début de la pandémie
par contre je voudrais souligner que à
la demande du ministère il y a eu des
annulations de colloque non pas par des
groupuscules étudiants mais pas par
l'autorité publique par notre autorité
de tutelle qui a prétendu sans s'ingérer
en fait dans l'organisation de colloques
alors que nous sommes nous avons la
garantie de notre liberté académique et
ça ça n'a visiblement gêné personne à
l'époque ça s'est passé en 2017
il ya eu des enseignants chercheurs des
chercheurs qui ont été mis en cause leur
probité
parce qu'il voulait développer des
colloques qui avait été parfaitement
validé et financé d'ailleurs et donc au
dernier moment il ya une espèce
d'emballement idéologie
de panique morale qui a conduit à la
remise en cause de ces colloques parce
qu'il parlait d' islamophobie
parce que non pas il en parle sur un
mode polémique et politiques qu'ils en
parlent pour étudier le phénomène pour
l'examiner pour le documenter nous
sommes dans des démarches de
compréhension du monde et non pas dans
des démarches de d'inflexion du monde
selon l'orientation idéologique qui
serait la nôtre ça on le laisse aux
politiques qu'ils le font très mal
actuellement alors justement jean michel
insiste là-dessus
notre travail c'est d'être à
l'université c'est de faire de la
recherche si je me trouve ce soir devant
vous ce n'est pas tant parce que je
prête une grande importance à ce genre
d'exercice c'est parce que nous y sommes
contraints par le climat qui est imposé
par le gouvernement depuis des mois et
depuis un peu plus d'une semaine par
notre ministre de tutelle des ministres
de tout cas jean michel blanquer air à
lui appuyé les propos de frédéric dalle
l'islamo gauchisme et selon lui je cite
un fait social indubitable cécile relax
vous avez conscience dans la majorité de
ce terrain glissant précisément dans
lequel peut être vos amis frédéric vidal
aujourd'hui c'est une polémique dont
vous vous seriez peut-être passé où
finalement elle est assez saine et ma
foi il faut débattre de tout et on y va
franchement moi je pense qu'il faut des
bacs de tout mais par contre la
polémique dans laquelle on est actuel et
oui c'est un terrain glissant sur lequel
je ne souhaite pas je souhaite pas aller
là par là pour le coup ce que madame
gheniff dénonce et je ne peux qu'abonder
dans son sens c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons quand même une situation dans les
universités qui est extrêmement
difficile pour nos étudiants et la
priorité elle est véritablement la
soutenir nos étudiants particulièrement
nos étudiants les plus précaires faire
en sorte qu'aujourd'hui il puisse y
avoir des cours qui reprennent
moi je sais que je suis extrêmement
attentive à cela donc sur mon territoire
c'est l'université de cergy pontoise
je sais que depuis le mois de janvier
j'ai rencontré des étudiants j'ai
rencontré régulièrement
avec le président de l'université parce
qu'il ya une grande volonté des
enseignants du président à des étudiants
de pouvoir reprendre un rythme normal et
en effet ça c'est une priorité et ça
doit être la priorité
donc c'est pour ça que je ne pour le
coup je ne peux pas cautionner ces
polémiques qui nous éloigne en effet du
véritable du véritable sujet mais là où
je ne suis pas d'accord avec madame
gagnon faisait que passer
en fait je suis d'accord avec madame
gheniff lorsqu'elle dit c'est son boulot
en effet c'est son travail d'enseignant
chercheur et il faut qu'il y ait ces
recherches sur toutes les thématiques
que nous quel hacker l'aborder nous ce
que l'on dénonce en tant que politique
c'est le fait de dérives et lorsque vous
dites qu'il n'ya pas forcément moins pop
que je parle le groupuscule parce que
lorsqu'il ya des pièces de théâtre
lorsqu'il ya des conférences qui sont
annulés je suis désolé ce n'est pas que
c'est pas vous les enseignants qui
interdisait les ce sont des étudiants ce
sont des personnes extérieures
mais en fait nous on a été en fait
alerté bon ça fait trois ans que j'ai je
suis alerter régulièrement elle
régulièrement par des étudiants pas des
enseignants des étudiants que 10 là nous
il ya des cours on peut pas les suivre
que ce soit la sorbonne que ce soit à
paris xiii que ce soit à nanterre
université puisque ce sont des
universités d'île de france
voilà c'est la cc c'est pour ça que
manger je suis assez attentive là dessus
frédéric vidal doit-elle à partir chez
longère je pense que en tant que députés
la majorité je n'ai pas à me prononcer
là dessus puisque c'est une décision
gouvernementale jeu une chose est sûre
c'est que s'il ya une maladresse qui a
été commise dans les propos de la
ministre je pense que elle a d'ailleurs
depuis bien repris et ré expliquer ce
qu'elle voulait faire c'est à dire de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait non pas une
enquête mais bel et bien peut-être des
travaux supplémentaires délégué à aller
en s'atténuant donc sous couverture du
cnrs voilà de 2,2 voilà 2 qu'il y ait
ces théories qui soit peut-être
approfondie dans des travaux
interdisciplinaires
mais là ce n'est pas du tout le monde n
je pense que madame gheniff pour en
parler beaucoup mieux de
que moi parce que je n'en ai fait je ne
suis pas au fait des spécificités de ces
théories qui sont l'apanage des sciences
humaines et sociales et il faut laisser
à nos enseignants chercheurs à nos
spécialistes aussi le soin de bien
expliquer ces concepts et là dessus avec
man vnx pense qu'on sera d'accord qu'il
faut que ces concepts soit enseigné
qu'il soit débattu parce qu'en effet
permettre à nos sociétés d'évoluer et de
comprendre certaines choses en jeu les
intentions
oui annonce modéré vie le mot de la fin
aujourd'hui clairement on l'a compris
puisque vous êtes signataire on le
rappelle de cette tribune vous demander
le départ de frédéric vidal mais
finalement n'est-il pas ça comme vous le
faites d'ailleurs et on vous en remercie
ce soir de venir débattre et expliquer
et finalement dissiper tous les
malentendus parce que manifestement il y
en a des malentendus puisque deux camps
y compris au sein de la gauche
d'ailleurs qui se divise sur ces thèmes
voilà il ya des choses peut-être non dit
pas expliquer ce que ce débat mais qu'il
passait au final est est-ce qu'il n'est
pas plutôt salvateur de la voir alors
tous les débats sont salvateurs nous ne
cessons de le pratiquer de l'enseigné à
nos étudiants le problème c'est les
circonstances dans lesquelles il est
imposé c'est la teneur qui nous est
aussi imposée c'est à dire cette chasse
aux sorcières cette façon de désigner
des coupables ou des formes de deux
logiques qui viserait à
à déformer l'esprit des étudiants donc
tout ça en fait est particulièrement
nocif tout cela est une perte de temps
pour tout dire
ces débats ont lieu ils sont
particulièrement productif les études et
les enquêtes qui repose sur ces théories
ont lieu elles ne sont pas assez
financer et l'état d'ailleurs du
financement de l'enseignement supérieur
je le rappelle ne risque pas de
faciliter les choses en retz dans les
années à venir puisque ce ne sont pas
des dotations pérenne mais c'est bien
des demandes de financement qu'il faut
passer sa vie à faire pour obtenir des
financements faire la recherche donc
pour toutes ces raisons aujourd'hui je
pense que effectivement le départ de la
ministre s'impose parce que elle a non
seulement ella ella ella ella chercher à
décrédibiliser le monde universitaire à
partir de cette accusation d'islam au
gauchisme qui n'est toujours pas précisé
d'ailleurs et qui continue de produire
des effets délétères et elle s'est
détourné de ses responsabilités à notre
égard en faisant faut voter des lois qui
aujourd'hui vont avoir des conséquences
gravissimes sur l'enseignement supérieur
si on ne met pas un coup d'arrêt à tout
cela donc la première chose à faire
effectivement c'est qu'elle parte pour
ce qui est d'organiser des débats des
controverses
nous savons le faire nous le faisons
régulièrement peut-être qu'au fond il y
a une difficulté consiste à s'intéresser
un peu plus à ce qui se passe à
l'université est un peu moins au twitter
et autres formules à l'emporte-pièce qui
sont constamment en train de caricaturer
la réalité
si effectivement on comprenait au
sérieux on accordait la considération
nécessaire et légitime au milieu
universitaire et à ce qui s'y produit
sans doute que certains débats ne serait
épargné
celui ci en est un merci à vous en tout
cas nacira guénif cécile il a d'être
venus débattre en direct sur rtl france
merci à toutes les deux